[Music]  okay next question please  yes yep  just up here and urine from NRK in  Norway and the broadcasting with Judit  Polgar she's couldn't understand why you  were playing so long in the end game so  when did you understand that this was a  draw so I think the question for you why  are you playing so on so long when did  you understand it was a draw  when did I understand it was a draw I  understood it immediately doesn't mean  you shouldn't play I'm trying to entice  him to play to play h5 and if it does  play h5 then I at least have a target  but obviously if you just keep still and  keeps his forretress just waiting for  waiting for my king to enter then  there's then there's nothing but I mean  there's no harm harm in playing and III  really don't understand the points  ohh-kay anymore for anymore  [Music]  [Music]